and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood here on uncensored
tonight are gender critics akin to
fascists that's what the smps Mary Black
seems to be claiming the Scottish
politician has accused of Bad actors of
hijacking the debate over transgender
rights is she just trying to stifle Free
Speech or does she have a point we're
going to be debating that now it is the
killer mushroom mystery that is gripping
the world we'll be live from Australia
the latest on how a woman's in-laws died
after eating lunch at her house and he
is the self-proclaimed hardest Giza and
he's on a mission to become the first
person ever to run the full length of
Africa Russ Cook has had several
setbacks since his journey began in
April but he is back on track I'll be
speaking to him later in the show
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood
now this is Morgan said to me Rosanna
Lockwood in the chair for the big man
again tonight now who predicted Scotland
would become the epicenter of the UK's
gender debate did you have that in your
bingo card it is almost six months
exactly since Nicholas sturgeon resigned
as first Minister citing a long-term
assessment of her role but shortly
before an investigation was announced
into SNP finances that's the party she
was with and shortly after she said this
are all trans women women they haven't
answered that question well that's not
the point that we're dealing with yeah
trans women are women but in the present
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where a
trans woman is not a woman no there is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate now she did say it wasn't those
sort of short-term pressures around
those comments that caused her to quit
but the s p had been pushing legislation
to allow Scottish people to change their
legal sex from man to woman or woman to
Man simply by signing a declaration But
ultimately that move was blocked by
Westminster and now another SNP MP has
come out on the attack on behalf of the
trans movement Mary Black she was once
Britain's youngest MP in 350 years when
she was first elected age 20 she has
been slamming people who intellectually
intellectually criticized the extension
of trans rights and Society saying
they're bad actors radicalizing people
on online and get this she described
them as 50 year old Karen's do you know
what she means by that a lot of you
apparently do because the word Karen was
actually trending across X or Twitter or
whatever you call it social media in the
UK today off the back of all this the
idea of a Karen I remind you if you
don't know it stems from the internet
meme showing a white middle-aged woman
who demands to speak to the manager the
suggestion is that Karen is a
closed-minded and overly privileged
woman who abuses her privileges to get
her demands met now you can understand
then why many self-described middle-aged
women with opinions on gender matters
took offense at that comment some
pointing out that one day 28 year old
Mary Black herself will be a 50 year old
white woman
something I can agree with black on
though is this response she gave when
she was asked at this event she was
speaking at the Edinburgh Fringe
Festival and she was saying all this
stuff
she was asked what makes a decent person
and she said to me a decent person is
someone who tries to make others
comfortable and accept them particularly
when it's a marginalized oppressed group
that's just human progress and to me
being decent is being part of that
progress not hindering it now definitely
see the point she's trying to make there
but what if she extended that logic to
the many women she offended with her
words you can't preach peace and then
declare war with her name calling and
insults Mary Black is feeding into the
toxic public discourse she says she's
against but that is free speech isn't it
if you really really believe an
intellectual debate and Free Speech you
have to hear it from all sides so short
of everyone staying decent which we're a
bit far past at this point especially on
this show then no one should try to shut
Mary Black Down For What She Said Today
about Karen's Bad actors as much as Mary
Black shouldn't try to shut down others
for the views they expressed different
to her own a right to be offended yes of
course everyone's got that right but
freedom of expression and debate should
never come at the expense of that
joining me to debate all of this talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow in the studio
and former labor special advisor and
co-founder of the left-wing campaign
group momentum James Schneider also
joining us from New York is the former
conservative MP Louise Mensch thank you
both well three of you all of you for
making time this evening uh James I will
come to you first on this if you don't
mind
um and just talk a little bit about
those comments made by Mary Black do you
think it's all right for her to compare
what she essentially said was gender
critics so people who are against the
idea of extending trans rights in
society she said the people who are
intellectually debating that are akin to
people who made same claims about race
so sort of almost saying there's a sort
of Supremacy thing going on here almost
akin to fascists you didn't say those
words directly but that's the comparison
that's been made the telegraph
headlining that today do you think it's
okay for her to make those comparisons
well what she said or what she seems to
have said is that the media and
politicians should leave trans people
the hell alone I think was her quote and
in that of course she's right that this
you know in that quote you read out
about being decent there's this small
very small group in society that is
marginalized and it is vulnerable and
there is politically attacked again and
again and attacked in the media again
and again with scarce scare stories and
falsehoods but what I'm interested in is
not that itself I think you know trans
people should be protected and their
rights should be protected and so on and
so forth but why is it that that's
happening why has it become such a major
issue in the media in in politics when
it's a very marginal issue it affects a
very small number of people and if you
look at all of the polling over recent
years not that many people care that
much about it and I think the reason why
it's become such a major political issue
is to divide us because for the
overwhelming majority of people life is
harder than it was 10 15 years ago and
so rather than the media and politics
discussing how we can boost our pay how
we can reduce our mortgages in our rent
how we can reduce our bills how we can
finally tax the super rich to pay for
our Public Services we're having these
kind of ridiculous cultural arguments
which are Super marginal and actually
probably if we had Mary Black here the
way in which he would say it would
probably be quite decent and reasonable
and the person criticizing her would
and there wouldn't be such a fundamental
route but she didn't she she made those
points but at the same time Esther
bringing you into this conversation do
you think the words that she chose fed
into her line about being decent well
really the thing is one of one of the
things that she said that I found
interesting was she said these um people
trying to intellectualize the debate
around trans rights which I don't
understand what the problem is you truly
want intellectual debates on on an issue
what is it do you want policy to be
created on the back of anti-intellectual
debates that's ludicrous anyway but she
said a lot of the people that fund these
groups that are critical of gender
ideology are far-right groups based in
the US that are mainly sort of
fundamentalist Christians yeah
conservative or Christians exactly and I
think that's really not touching on the
issue because at the end of the day many
groups are funded in many different ways
you can make you can extend that
argument to many things I think one of
the problems we have here is I
understand the point that you know in
the grand scheme of things they're only
like 10 trans people in the UK really
and so I understand what your point
about it's a bit of a distraction but I
think that is the Trap that labor has
fallen into because people like istama
don't seem to understand the magnitude
of the issue not because there are so
many trans people that it affects every
single person in the UK but because when
they when women biological women feel
like politicians aren't taking these
issues seriously when you know issues
real real uh real issues like you know
female shelters is women's Sports
women's prisons when they come into the
debate when you try and trivialize it
and say actually this is a red herring
that's when people get really irate what
most people want is just clarification
on the law I completely agree let trans
people do what they want let them live
their lives but when it comes to public
policy and actual legal uh
clarifications on these matters that's
when it really you know it really stings
because that's what most people are
concerned with most people don't think
about trans people in their day-to-day
lives excuse me most people have never
even met a trans person but when you're
talking about the law and the definition
of male and female and what the
implications that has for you know
female prisons and shelters and all of
that that's when you need to take it
seriously and I think we need to be very
careful about trivializing that well and
the legislation is what led to a lot of
this debate within the s p party and
what Scotland was trying to get down
that Let's cross over to Louise mench in
New York standing by listening to this
um overseas so you come at this with an
interesting perspective and well first
of all can I say that producers Louise
let me know that you are I hope you
don't mind me sharing this above the age
of 50 which I was actually quite shocked
by um
because I thought you were quite a bit
younger how do you feel about that
wording that Mary Black used then to
describe the group that you belong to a
white woman in her 50s
well you also flattering maybe you
should be the politician uh I actually
think that it's ageist and for somebody
that considers herself to be a
progressive politician coming out and
dismissing an entire class of women
because of their age doesn't seem to me
to be very forward-thinking at all
um it's not just uh Aegis it's also
sexist of course there is no male Karen
equivalent it's just something that's
flung at middle-aged women and she is
obviously totally wrong half of the
strongest so-called gender critical I
would call them gender realist critics
of extremist trans ideology are lesbians
are but they're black women there are
Muslim women they come from all sections
of society JK Rowling who's one of the
most uh prominent of these opponents
lives in Scotland and of course has been
a labor party supporter all her life so
I think what she's saying is what she
wishes was true not what's actually true
there's a consensus in society I think
about the trust issue most people think
you should be polite and you should
address people how they want to be
addressed but we also recognize that you
cannot change your biological sex and if
people would just agree to that agree to
that consensus you can't change your
biological sex in some spaces should be
be reserved for people who are
biologically women this whole row would
go away I think to be fair to the labor
MP in question here she is 28 uh SNP
sorry smpm it's been a long day she is
28 she's only a year older than me
unfortunately we're part of that
generation that uses those terms I'm not
saying it was particularly wise for her
to use that term but I I understand what
she's trying to say because in on the
online speed context the Karen is just
you know and I understand it can be it
seems sexist and all of that but I don't
think it's as egregious as it's being
made out to to to be I think if she just
you know misspoke I think it was she if
she was probably uh in a more
professional setting she would have
chosen her words more carefully but I
think the overarching issue here is the
legality of you know male and female how
that affects you know women in public
spaces for instance and all of that
that's really the Crux of the issue not
whether trans people are being allowed
to live their lives or whether people
care about what you identify as on
Tuesday on Thursday or whatever what I'm
getting from this actually between the
three of you is quite a lot of consensus
here that people do understand that it's
actually a minority group issue people
would rather trans people were allowed
to get on with their lives than everyone
else would as well but what happens is
we do have this toxic narrative around
it James you were explaining first why
you think that is the case and why this
has got somewhat out of hand
in that sense then how do you
de-escalate it do you think we need
um because the risk here is that you
stymie intellectual debate if you say we
just need to all shut up about it but
then as Esther pointed out laws get
passed and people think I wasn't aware
of that I wasn't aware that now so and
so can use this changing room or that
bathroom and then they get quite
concerned do you think there is still a
cause for this intellectual debate to
happen about trans rights well if there
were going to be a sensible debate that
for example accepted that sex is in the
equality act that there's a difference
between sex and gender that's in already
in the law and what we're talking about
is marginal cases but that isn't what
happens you know the people who are most
bellowing about female prisons are of
course not long-standing members of the
Howard league for penal reform they're
people that generally speaking don't
care about prisoners the rest of the
time but it's helping them make this
particular argument so I mean of course
you could have a sensible debate you
could have a serious discussion about it
it just that isn't that isn't our
politics and media is set up because the
average person yes the average person
may not be particularly concerned with
the conditions of prisoners in prisons
but they understand that these kinds of
things can trickle down into their own
lives so for instance today it's having
a male rapist in a female prison
tomorrow you could have a male that's
entitled to share a female battle with
your teenage daughter they're real world
implications I don't think it's fair to
just say you must you know dedicate your
life to this particular course to care
about that actually and this is the
point that women have been making and
I'm not trying to say because you're a
man you don't understand it but again
this is this is why it's important to
not trivialize their concerns and you
know use such callous language as this
MP has because you're stepping on a lot
of people's toes I'm not trip lines
saying they're concerns but what I'm
saying is when you see the headlines
like the one on the telegraph which is
not a quote it's a scare thing it's
mental it's meant to generate a negative
reaction it's meant to make this debate
more and more toxic more and attached
more and more division the purpose of
that from the Telegraph and from most
the media which is owned by billionaires
is to make us divided and not allow us
to talk about things like how do we
increase our pay and how would we tax
the rich because that isn't in the
interest of most politicians
Louise before we run out of time and
just say that uh some in the political
circles were calling Louise on Mary
Black to uh not only standard stand
there which I think she's planning on
doing but they're saying she was unfit
for office off the back of these
comments that she doesn't have the
intellectual capacity to carry forward
legislation as needed by an MP do you
agree with that
I don't agree that she doesn't have the
intellectual capacity she seems like a
very bright young woman but I do agree
that she isn't fit for office because
she is willing to castigate and
categorize an entire group of people
that don't agree with her and as we all
know after the route about the trans
rapist in the women's prison most of
Scotland doesn't agree with her so
perhaps it's a good thing that she's
stepping down I don't completely
um agree with the idea that this is just
a controversy that's being created it is
a real controversy people care about it
I care about women's sports women not
getting gold medals because men are
competing in their categories I
especially care about gender so-called
affirming surgeries being done on minors
who can't consent to a beer in the
United States for example they can't
vote they can't have sex but somehow
they can alter their bodies forever
um in ways that they're clearly not
mature enough to do so I think we do
like Esther says we need some
notifications from Westminster
government as to what the law should be
and if the law was clearly defined then
all of this would go away Louise Esther
James thank you all for joining this
conversation this evening it's been
fascinating
well I'm censored next tonight the
Mysteries surrounding killer mushrooms
after three people die and one is left
fighting for their life will have the
very latest on that story that's
engulfed a small Australian Town coming
up next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now bringing
you this tragic story that has gripped
not only Australia but now the rest of
the world almost two weeks ago a family
gathered for lunch in a small town in
rural Australia a day later four people
fell ill and within a week three were
dead it is suspected that a deadly
mushroom might have been served at the
meal and that might have played a part
here's what we know so far 48 year old
Erin Patterson here she is she invited
her former in-laws Gail and Don
Patterson plus Gail's sister and husband
Heather and Ian Wilkinson over for lunch
during the lunch she served a dish with
mushrooms that Erin claimed she bought
from a local store it turns out that
those mushrooms were not edible and
likely were death cat mushrooms which
are the most poisonous mushrooms in the
world now three of her four guests are
dead from suspected mushroom poisoning
with Mr Wilkinson fighting for his life
still in hospital now Erin Patterson has
vehemently denied any wrongdoing
joined Now by Australian foraging expert
Ingrid button also forensic pathologist
Dr Michael Barden who has worked on a
mushroom poisoning case himself and Sky
News Australia host Jenna Clark joins us
first of all Jenna if we could go to you
please we want to talk to you a little
bit about the details on this story I
know you've been tracking it closely
just just fill in an international
audience and what they need to know
yeah absolutely horrifying scenes in a
small town in rural Victoria Rosanna
it's about 150 kilometers southeast of
Melbourne so it's a very tight-knit
Community they all about four of them
went to lunch uh as you said a couple of
Sundays ago and three of them are now
dead I have an update this morning uh
Ian Wilkinson who is one of the
gentlemen who is in a critical condition
he now requires a liver transplant and
there's news just breaking that Erin
Patterson's estranged husband Simon his
two parents Don and Gail passed away
after that meal he was actually in an
induced coma about this time last year
after a suspected poisoning with an
issue with his small intestine The
Herald sun which is a local newspaper
here in Australia is reporting that
they've seen social media posts which
pertain to that so this story has got a
lot of legs left to go it does and just
one more thing Jenna um in terms of
Aaron's husband or a strange husband
partner and he also got sick last year
what what can you tell us about that
yeah so we have um apparently twice last
year he was quite ill he felt quite ill
and was in an induced coma for 16 days
and required acute surgery on his small
intestine but in a social media post
that a number of outlets have seen here
in Australia he did thank he's now a
strange wife Aaron for her support
during that time but then we have a
headline on the front of the Herald's
son today saying something like she
tried to poison me but it's important to
note that the Victorian forensic
detectives are saying that Ms Patterson
has been questioned she hasn't been
ruled out yet as a suspect and they've
also been to a local tip and they've
retrieved a dehydrator a food dehydrator
which they're now testing for death cuff
death cap mushrooms yeah I mean because
it must be restated here that obviously
investigations are still very much
ongoing it's actually almost like a lack
of information that is causing a lot of
speculation to fill the void as you have
you said that we did mention that Aaron
the lady at the center as she's denied
this
spoke to reports outside her house and
she was actually distraught that these
family-in-law members had died she
didn't mean to do it's nothing to do
with her she said let's take a listen to
that
and you guys don't have any respect for
no just that little clip there you can
see though that terribly stressed
obviously but tons of speculation here
but we'll have to wait and see the
outcome the investigation let's speak to
some experts then on this uh coming
first to You Ingrid you're in there in
Australia again you got up very early to
speak to us we do appreciate that uh you
are a foraging expert you specialize in
mushrooms you're based in Australia in
fact I believe in the state where this
is all taking place so how did you feel
when you heard this story because you're
aware of the dangers of mushrooms aren't
you
absolutely devastated to be honest and
us in the foraging Community have been
waiting for something like this for
quite some time it's really a atmosphere
of uh sort of bragging around a lot of
mushrooms and a lot of online
identification of incorrect mushrooms uh
so we're not obviously casting any blame
there but it is a really dangerous
activity to go for a day especially if
you don't know what you're doing and
death cap mushrooms are really easily
misidentified as three other mushrooms
so they are also responsible for nine
out of ten Global mushroom deaths so
this is not the first time this has
happened and let's hope it's the last
how easy is it to make a mistake when it
when foraging you know you educate
people on this um
is it possible to make an honest mistake
it is uh if you don't know what you're
doing as I said it can be a really
dangerous thing if you have attended one
of my educational workshops you wouldn't
have done so purely because we have
three simple rules regarding foraging
number one if in doubt live a doubt
number two white girls probably kills
and number three if it stains yellow or
green you should not be keen and death
cat mushrooms are those specific
mushrooms mentioned so if it's yellow or
green and has a tinge on the mushroom
that is a clear sign that it is not an
edible mushroom crikey I mean I don't
like mushrooms anyway so not at risk of
this but the thought of picking the
wrong one is terrifying Let's cross the
Dr Michael now to my understanding you
have worked on a mushroom toxicology
case before I just want to tell the
viewers as well some of the work you've
been involved in you chaired the panel
on reinvestigating the deaths of
President John F Kennedy Dr Martin
Luther King You've also been an expert
investigations on George Floyd Jeffrey
Epstein OJ Simpson among others and the
host of your own HBO autopsy just to
give our viewers a little sense of who
we're speaking to here tell us a little
bit about that mushroom case if you
wouldn't mind on how how you go about
investigating something like this yeah
when I was a chief medical examiner in
New York City we had a couple a
middle-aged couple who had gone foraging
uh in the woods for mushrooms as they
did
a number of times earlier and they
picked up this in in this case it was a
white mushroom but it can be green or
yellow or even Brown uh which turned out
to be the Amanita falloides
mushroom uh also called the destroying
angel
um and um uh the difficult part of it is
the toxicology doesn't usually help the
it's the history it's a Delayed Action
mushroom that is a person doesn't
fill the symptoms
liver damage kidney damage for maybe 12
hours 24 36 hours
when they become sick they become sick
with violent vomiting with bloody
diarrhea
and uh whatever the toxins are in the
body get metabolized so when they die
there isn't much uh chemicals to work
with and it's the history of eating the
mushrooms how they obtain the mushrooms
uh and uh that helps in determining
whether it's an accident or homicide or
suicide any of them could happen with
the deadly mushrooms with this mushroom
but what's interesting is is how
the prepare the mushrooms
obtain the mushrooms and
um
the symptoms the the chemicals the
poisons start damaging the liver and the
kidneys right away but it isn't
symptomatic for a day or so and that's
why it's so difficult to
find it from a chemical point of view
and as Jenna laid out to us the details
on this story the start you know
investigators still piecing together or
they they know but they're not telling
us yet with regard to how the mushrooms
were obtained if they were directly a
cause of the death of these people who
ate them and at what times I mean How
likely is it that they can get a clear
answer given the information that has
been made available that we know they've
got so far
well it would depend on where she
obtained the mushrooms it's unlikely
that she got it for the local store and
the only people who were injured were
the uh people the four people involved
and an uh a part of it has already been
mentioned the treatment for the the
severe poisoning is a liver or kidney
transplants you know there's no uh
antidote for the for the toxins but it
depends on the detectives
finding where the mushrooms came from
whether it could have been foraging
accidental because these are beautiful
looking mushrooms for people who are
unfamiliar with what they look like they
look like prized mushrooms to us non
foragers like myself and they can cause
severe uh life-threatening deaths and
it's the most common mushroom I mean I'm
going to falluities in the United States
and India and in England in Australia
that causes death I actually want to
come back to Ingrid quickly and ask then
the likelihood you think of whether it
was possible this did get into a store
in the town where she lived
you took the words out of my mouth the
likelihood of that occurring is pretty
much impossible so first of all all
mushrooms supplied two shops will be
from the mushroom farm they are grown in
a different medium these particular
mushrooms death cap mushrooms aminita
palloides require a host tree
particularly Oak
so the likelihood of them winding up for
sale if either needed to be through a uh
third party through some sort of
suspicious uh purchase or sale there we
have seen a lot of Facebook posts and
sales with people using other people's
photos and selling mushrooms that way so
it could have been from a disreputable
Source but the likelihood of you of
buying the incorrect mushroom from the
supermarket is nigh on Impossible I I
really strongly
would be absolutely shocked if that was
the case to be honest thank you both for
showing your expertise with us this
evening Jenna thank you for reporting
just quickly uh when can we expect
further updates do you know
uh probably within the next couple of
hours Rosanna we're expecting Victoria
Place to hold another press conference
wonderful thank you I'm sure we'll be
back to you when this story develops all
three of you thank you for joining us
thank you uncensored next tonight the
SAS hero of the Iranian Embassy Siege
Rusty Furman joins me live here in the
studio we'll be discussing the current
Iranian threats within the UK plus
whether it is right that the government
is considering sending migrants to the
isolated Ascension Island while all of
that next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King q
that figure is only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin fault don't mean they're
kinfo do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to oncense with me Rosanna
Lockwood in the chair for peers now
ministers are reportedly considering
sending Asylum Seekers here in Britain
to a remote island over 4 000 miles from
the UK in another ploy to stop the boats
this volcanic island Ascension Island
it's called it was used as a strategic
military base during the Falklands War
and the RAF do continue to operate there
now this has been described as a radical
Plan B for if the Rwanda scheme was
ruled unlawful by the Supreme Court so
is it a real possibility or just a rumor
what is life on the Ascension Island
actually like will it be safe do people
even mind that at this point some
quarters seemingly not joining me to
discuss all of this Rusty Furman sasb
Squadron veteran who spent time training
on that island back in 1980 there's a
picture of young Rusty there he also
played an Integra role in the Iranian
Embassy Siege of 1980 there was the
famous picture of the man without the
gloves during that famous Siege in
London a lot of our viewers will
remember that uh good to have you in the
studio Rusty thanks for the invite well
you know what we just wanted a
conversation with you generally because
it's always interesting to talk with a
man that's had the career you've had but
particularly off the Ascension Island
um proposal because you've been there
first off just what's it like
um well it's a long time since I've been
there obviously 1982 when the Falkland
Island conflict was on but
um it's big and spacious and I think the
migrants would love it there do you
really absolutely love it yes have a
whale of a time you know with the ocean
there and everything what's there to do
nothing yeah right so what makes you
think they'd love it so that's what
they're doing here isn't it let's come
here
and they don't do anything apart from
collecting money
and get housed why not go there put the
barges off all the way around the
Ascension Island 88 square kilometers
put it down there loads of room very
much like their climate
not far from Africa 4 000 miles from us
I defy them to get into dinghy and come
from Ascension Islands to the UK and
make it now that is a view that people
in this country do share
um I appreciate that I'm not here to
tell you you're wrong I have a different
opinion of how we should handle migrants
particularly given that the Rwanda
scheme which is failing through the
courts at the moment it was found that
the cost of sending one migrant to
Rwanda would be 169
000 pounds per migrant which is 63 000
pounds more than keeping them in the UK
I'm not saying keep all migrants in the
UK but we do have to have a better
scheme for processing rather than just
sending people elsewhere surely yeah
well let's process them down there take
them down there
okay at the moment we've got our borders
to secure right the two things that
Zoella braveman are letting go and the
Very two things he's in charge of the
force areas should be kept secure and
our borders but we're letting people in
who aren't you know they could be from
anywhere any background
predominantly fighting male age
all coming across here
why not send them there process them
there properly I didn't mean stay there
forever in the day process them and then
when you're ready bring them in and have
a system that works it's not something
astonishingly expensive and complicated
to you because getting everyone over
there a processing center currently
there's 800 people living on the island
they're not even citizens they're not
allowed to be there's a British overseas
territory in their temporary residence
essentially there's barely any buildings
there's barely any infrastructure as you
said there's basically nothing there so
you want to set up an asylum processing
center over on a central island yeah let
them go there set up a bit of an
infrastructure for them I say they're
not going to be there forever but don't
bring them here they're fighting all the
way around the UK people don't want them
bring them in when they're ready to come
in as many as you need but don't overdo
it give our borders a rest and give
somebody else the pleasure of having the
migrants I mean it's still our work it's
a British overseas territory it's not
handing them over to a different country
Rwanda scheme is handing them to
somebody else but also ensuring there is
housing and jobs Ascension would just be
creating an offshore processing center
in the middle of the South Atlantic yeah
but that's fine we wonder if they don't
want them they're not going to go there
are they Rusty I don't think you and I
are going to agree on this one at all
well you know that's why I'm here yeah
it is it is why you're here
um I just find it interesting from a
military man somebody who has been so
involved in logistics for so long that
you think that would be a rational
proposal to this situation how many
migrants are there I mean about
thousands tens of thousands all the time
a lot of people in this country agree
there is an issue controlled immigration
there's an issue in this country well
let's try and help it let's see if it
works let's not rule it out you know if
it's going to cost that amount of money
to get them there then and it can be
processed properly is that not better
than um maybe making our borders not
secure I think a lot of people would
agree with secure borders whether or not
you want to do that in the South
Atlantic on a tiny Island at Great cost
of the British taxpayer look let's talk
about something else as well while
you're here I wanted to bring you in on
um because this is on Iran we just
talked about the Iranian Embassy Siege
and over the weekend we learned that Sue
Ella brathman the Home Secretary uh
their their office believed there is a
real issue in this country with regards
to Iranian spies
um basically recruiting within organized
gangs because they're funny much harder
to get Iranians in and that have
malicious intent after the Salisbury
poisonings you were involved in the
Iranian Siege back then how concerned
are you by the this well I mean Iran is
a big problem I mean a lot of people
know that but what can you do about it
you've got the government and the
foreign officer a foreign office sorry
they're not together on this you know um
if you want to get to the bottom of it
there's a split in the government and
the foreign office and it's all down to
do with it's all to do with not wanting
to upset
the Iranians now you can have it both
ways you can have your board is secure
because let's be honest we are an island
you can have them wanting to and I think
the last count was 15 credible threats
against
um people in the UK from the Iranians
um we don't do anything about it because
we don't want to upset them what about
for once
go back to the Falklands get proactive
and deal with it before something
happens not wait till it happens and
then deal with it some of the split
you're talking about is home office
ministers some of them have been pushing
for the Iranian revolutionary guard to
be described as a terrorist organization
but others are pushing back because
they're worried particularly from the
phone foreign office that that will
affect diplomatic ties to the United
Kingdom and Iran and you're saying get
harder on that yeah call them terrorists
everything else can you understand that
that would make things very difficult
when it comes to things like negotiating
weapons and nuclear Armament agreement
and the return of hostages yeah
um I I fully agree with that I've been
through all my life but what I do find
is when we had a leader who led
they dealt with it which leader was that
in your mind Margaret Thatcher yeah okay
um so in my day we had leaders who led
I'm afraid that the leaders we've got in
this country I wouldn't follow the
amount of curiosity none of them okay we
need to be harder and you know what
everybody's sliding down this scale of
saying oh what if what if we upset them
what if we do this well you know what
that's why we have that's why we have a
military capability you know we've got
to deal with stuff I want to ask you
about that because the British mod has
confirmed it's going to cut troop
numbers from 82 000 to 73 000 by 2025
obviously got the war happening in
Ukraine as well what do you make of the
current state of our Armed Forces here
in the UK I tell you what it's as bad as
I've ever seen it I personally wouldn't
join the Army again but that's just me
but the fact is they're cutting the
numbers
and my opinion when if you ever want to
get me in here and talk about the edu
European Defense Union which nobody
wants to talk about
because we're involved with all the
other countries they say of the European
Union the European no it's the European
Defense Union I can tell you that now
but they won't come clean on that so
they're thinking we've got all the other
countries with us we can make ours
smaller but we still need to defend our
Island that is the problem what makes
you say you wouldn't sign up to the Army
now if you had your time again because
I've seen how it's um how they're
treated I've seen how they prosecute
um veterans 40 and 50 years after
they've gone and served for the country
have been alongside them you know I'm a
painter in the three charities
you know and I've seen it close and I
don't like what I'm seeing nothing I
hate it is there any hope at the moment
given the governments you see coming
anybody in government that inspires you
to think that we'll get defense sorted
in a way you would like
um it might be interesting if they could
get some ex-military
involved but at the moment in my opinion
the Civil Service runs it all you know
we haven't got anybody that can stand up
nobody wants to stand up this isn't the
man that you would look to sorry Ben
Wallace
um
maybe but he didn't want to do it
so Ben Wallace is one
um I'd like somebody like Tim Collins or
somebody like that that I've served with
you know somebody's got a bit of
credibility and I've served with them so
I know
um but that's just me but it's got to be
somebody more than one I'm afraid it
needs a clear out it needs to start and
be a bit like the Iranians it needs to
be a bit more aggressive we'll take some
inspiration from the Iranians uh didn't
think we'd end there look Rusty Furman
thank you very much for coming in
speaking across a range of topics this
evening interesting stuff
uncensored next to night he's been held
at gunpoint kidnapped and even chased by
men with machetes as he's intended to
run the entire length of Africa Russ
Cook aka the hardest Giza will join me
live to tell me that despite not even
being halfway through the Journey he is
not giving up
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk violence breaks
out on London's Oxford Street as police
scramble to control their social media
fueled crime wave the biggest data
breach in British history puts tens of
millions of Voters data at risk and the
Royal Family's website removes any
mention of Harry and Megan's titles
that's all at nine o'clock
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back to Pierce Morgan on
scents with me Rosanna Lockwood now my
next guest is the self-proclaimed hard
Geezer who sorry I had to say it like
that who is attempting to be the first
person to run the length of Africa
that's 9
320 miles and not every day has gone to
plan let's take a look
so what were we thinking bad ideas are
on I'm getting Lads
two Lads came storming up the side of
the van one another one on a motorbike
and cracked open the door and uh
proceeded to the point of gun in all of
our faces and tell us to give give them
everything we had
well the hardest guy he's a rust cook
does join us now Russ where are you
hi everyone
um I'm I'm currently in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo okie dokie and uh
we've just seen a bit of a clip of uh
some things that have happened to you
along the way I've just got one question
why are you doing this
um
yeah people ask me this all the time I I
sort of say you know
um
of I've lived
um some experiences before that didn't
feel very meaningful to me I've spent a
lot of my time a lot of my life before
thinking you know what is the point in
being here and
um our part you know part of this
mission is that I'm going all guns
blazing
um to to try and make a difference try
and make something meaningful with my
life and and live life to the absolute
first stuff
um certainly getting some experiences
good and bad
um writing the entire life yeah well
look good for you is what I can say to
that and you know I I did sort of say
why you're doing this with a grin on my
face there because I cannot imagine
anything possessing me to do what you're
doing and it's because I couldn't it's
extraordinary the physical undertaking
you are doing I mean it's not all been
bad surely tell us some of the things
that have happened on the way that have
inspired you to figure out what the
meaning of life might be
there there's been so many things that
are inspired me I think you know one of
the things that really stands out is um
there's been so much kindness from so
many people that that really didn't have
any reason to be kind to us they just
you know uh just showing us you know
showing support for for what I'm trying
to do and uh you know hit countless
people have taken our sin and and cooked
us endless meals and uh you know just
try to sort us out with with loads of
help logistically you know just to get
the mission downloads people have joined
me to run we've had multiple people
running their first ever marathons you
know it's it's there's been so many
highest throughout the journey so I
thought you know that's incredible
that's great tell us a bit about the
remaining Journey you've got you're in
the DLC at the moment you're gonna make
your way around Western Africa up
through uh up to the northern how long
do you reckon that's going to take you
what are your concerns about that part
of the journey
honestly your guess is as good as mine
at this point because I thought the
whole thing was going to take 240 days
I'm currently 110 Days Inn and we're not
even halfway I'm not even close to
halfway yet I've got to go through uh
some Central African countries um and
then on like you said we're skirting
rounds to to West Africa or not up North
so I mean
if I'm if I'm done by next February I'll
be a happy boy incredible so my
girlfriends you'll be happy Russ how do
people support you how do they watch
your journey your progress how can they
donate to any charities
so I've got a give star link which can
be found
um in all of my social media buyers uh
we're raising money for the running
charity in Water Aid um you can find me
on any social media uh it's all uh at
hard diskusa at Hardy ski so you are a
hard Geezer in my estimation certainly
Russ well done signing out there in the
Democratic Republic of Congo coming to
the studio now uh with Esther and Kevin
who are listening in on that yeah
Kevin I'll come to you first
want to engage in bloke right right I
mean look I know there's a climate
emergency but no one would uh have a go
at them if you drove rather than I'm
gonna kind of remember foreign
fit it's like people swim in the channel
climbing Everest 20 times you know this
is
yeah a charity I'm glad he's not one of
those like Valley girls but like I'm
trying to find my myself I'm not in the
Congo but but he's doing this well
charity softens it um
from the perspective of somebody who has
family that are from a West African
nation and you know he's going to be
running up through West Africa I saw him
just running through my back I said who
is that hippie that yeah anyway
um I would highly recommend uh mosquito
repellent and Sun cream but all the best
so you support it broadly uh because
it's for charity not because I think he
has not not lost his mind let's move on
to talking a bit more about charity and
uh everyone's favorite uh charitable
philanthropist the Duke of Sussex who is
currently in Japan in Tokyo he's given a
speech uh today to a crowd saying he
actually prefers Tokyo to Montecito I
reckons he said Kobe steak for dinner
and lunch uh and he's going on after
this to Singapore to play in a polo
match
um and you know what when I was looking
at this story today I was thinking if
he's trying to bore us all into not
talking about him he's doing a pretty
good job because I failed to be moved by
a lot of what I was seeing and you know
he's on a charity tour that's what he's
doing he's raising money I mean Kevin do
you have a viewing it yeah you can't he
can't win Kenny he goes on it we all
have a go at him if he doesn't and he's
just lazy and back back home I'd rather
he went around making money for
Charities than he did for himself
I always think it's sad I about him the
missed opportunity with what they could
actually have done in the royal family
Harry and Megan I always think it's a
huge missed opportunity and you know if
their their aim was to do good and to be
charitable people I think there was no
greater institutional vehicle that they
could have done that through than the
royal family but at the moment he's just
a boring man traveling with his Boy Esto
is a British Republic and I'm thrilled
he's gone nowhere because I thought he
couldn't revital alive
at the moment he's what I just think he
was very bright but at the moment you
know he's he's doing boring things for
this boring wife and I wish them boring
well and people are continuing to talk
about him as we are there so you know
maybe he's the winner in all this let's
finally talk about this Shakespeare
being banned in schools in Florida this
after ruling by Governor Ron DeSantis
apparently Romeo and Juliet to raunchy
for kids what do you make of this story
because it's interesting isn't it um
often the left get accused of canceling
things but now we got this going on like
the right is where canceled culture
originated it's been there all the time
but I mean look it's ridiculous
I thought he's supposed to be for free
speech and Liberty in the states he's
not I mean it's just ludicrous
absolutely
what a strange progression I mean yes I
understand you know okay you don't want
to teach your kids gender ideology
because that should probably be in the
domain of the family and fine
Shakespeare one of the greatest
playwrights in history
um I mean strange okay well that is it
from us strange oh my God we've had
bravery and we've had boredom whatever
you're up to tonight make sure it is
uncensored definitely not boring we'll
see you back same time tomorrow good
night
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah King peers and
King Q I think there's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
they're skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war remember me cry again they're trying
to force you out yes I feel betrayed
keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen